[Music]
this forty second long epic DreamWorks
logo is unnecessarily epic and
unnecessarily DreamWorks he is my day so
far aeration my end starts at the
beginning starting with the climax
cliche coincidentally starting with the
climax is the working title for my sex
tape coming soon is the alternate title
here is your minion even non minion
minions now make me cringe you are dest
I didn't quite hear that last part but
it sounded important how does make a
mind even remember this in such detail
does this race have a photographic
memory from conception because honestly
the ramifications for that are a bit
unsettling sure the gravitational pull
of that black hole type thingy is enough
to be pulling that entire planet in at
an astonishing rate but an escape pod
the size of an infant I no worries it's
definitely gonna break free so they're
just gonna keep the baby in the prison I
guess in this world wherever a baby pops
up is where he or she is forced to live
coyote cares the equivalent of squatter
rights in the Mega Man universe also
they had flash cards at this prison how
many babies do they take in this is a
very dark society mr. Bokka hanging out
here eating humans as well is there that
I once again ran into mr. goody
two-shoes I know right it's almost as if
the unlikely convenience of your
continued childhood interaction is meant
to serve as some sort of story plot lot
of popcorn containers and movies act
like popcorn fire hydrants waiting to
spray across rooms like some sort of
curl based confetti cannon I get the
kids can be cruel but this teacher
should be fired immediately
letting a student dole out the
punishment allowing this to be the class
picture not involving all the students
in the crucial itsy bitsy spider
sing-along no matter how hard I tried I
was always the odd man out the last one
picked trouble child becomes even more
trouble than evil due to being the last
one picked for school sports cliche
also if you want to gang up on some kid
and throw dodgeballs at him there really
isn't a need to pick teams unless this
is a new dodgeball variant I'm unaware
was this my destiny hold on I would
think inventing something like this at a
young age would be a ton more impressive
than being stronger than everyone else
being bad is the one thing I'm good at
but has he been bad Megamind didn't do
anything to end up in prison he just
landed there and was raised by the
inmates and so far he's just made a few
harmless inventions and been picked on
by kids at school
sounds not too far off from a normal
life in the suburbs to me if I know the
law of inertia and I probably don't
unless those kids somehow buckled in
that rod there will be a lot of unhappy
parents of some very bruised up kids
after that unauthorized field trip
waiting I decided to pick something a
little more humble also we now enter
minute six of this bloated opening
exposition I swear if this wolf aeration
goes on much longer I may be the one who
goes full supervillain this is an
awfully big city for one of the
headlines on the front page of the local
paper to simply be shopping you're a
villain and you'll always be a villain
you'll never change and you'll never
leave your fun Megamind would be
diabolical at cinemasins also I wonder
if it was JK Simmons voice work here is
the law enforcement officer that got him
the role barely appearing as James
Corden in the DCU movies also also how
exactly are they talking to each other
that appears to be a steel door with a
glass plated window if they screamed at
each other they could maybe make out a
few words but they certainly wouldn't be
able to carry on a conversation like
this you were right I'll always be a
villain oh good
can't pass up those on the nose song
choices we're bad moon rising or the
boys are back in town not available also
he gives the guards at least a few more
seconds to take him down are they
required by law to listen to a villain
spawn before taking action why would
Metro City go through the trouble of
putting together a wall for Metro Man to
punch through if he's being honored he's
clear he's been around for a minute
saving people's lives and all those
people have seen him punch through walls
this is a lot of overhead for a
two-second bit Metro man cares not for
your puny human concepts like safety
parental consent or shaken baby syndrome
and I love you random citizen and I'm
going to show you this by splashing
every single one of you with a ton of
water like you were at a Shamu show down
at SeaWorld seriously I know they came
out the same year but this scent
despicable me are the same movie how did
this even happen two animated films
based on the villains viewpoint is very
fucking specific it's not like these
were just two movies about volcanoes or
Steve Prefontaine you call this
even if she did know the alligator thing
was gonna happen those are fucking
alligators and they are jumping two
inches from her face behind your plans
never work but he never closed the floor
right so there are still alligators
underneath rocks and while she's being
schmuck mice know I'm concerned about
these alligators Metrocity appears to be
a fairly large place but how many
abandoned observatories could there be
this dome is obviously lined with copper
copper drains my powers your weakness is
copper aside from not being a funny joke
how has this not come up once in the
whole time they've been battling each
other even though this ends up being
straight subterfuge it should have been
easy enough to prove false do they not
have pennies in Metro City wait a second
they're in Michigan and by the looks of
this laser pointer they're firmly mid
mitten and away from Lake Michigan last
I checked Cadillac area wasn't on the
coast as all the outside shots make it
appear to be also if they landed at
Christmas so I'm guessing the
environment here would have contained a
bit more winter weather than we're
seeing on these arrival shots believe me
I've been to Michigan in the winter it's
so cold there it makes the relationship
between Drake and push a tu look warm if
bi did it make a mine means he committed
brutal murder then yeah I guess he can
did it get dark ass kids movie wait that
worked
Megamind isn't holding any weapons he's
just walking toward the crowd
[Music]
why did the Minnie Riperton song even
start playing
that's a tape deck with one cassette
tape in it and highway to hell wasn't
finished so it should have just kept
belting out ac/dc
even if minion can't stop it movie
doesn't even know how to boombox
correctly I'm sure we'd all like to know
what you plan to do with us and this
city I'm not sure I understand why
anyone is even remotely concerned no one
seems afraid of mega mine
Roxanne wasn't even concerned after she
realized mega mine at trick Metro man
and he wouldn't be saving her the most
terrified by six mega mine oh that sir
is called a window how does micro mind
not even know what a window is he had
them in his school in his car and yes
even in his evil lair this ignorance is
not only unrealistic it's not even that
funny then why do I feel so manly the
running joke of mega Minds inability to
pronounce certain things is harshing my
mellow man melancholy and Metro City
have zero in common other than they
start with M and had the same number of
syllables if you make Metro City one
word but they sound different and they
have different inflections also he
pronounces Metro man right so why would
he say Metro City incorrectly shouldn't
be Metro Man I don't know how I don't
really feel like being around a bunch of
people no no that's the best part it'll
just be like you and me
nothing like including a bunch of sexual
preditor jokes in a kids movie battles
we will now never have why is she just
now hearing this
apparently the acoustics on this
observation deck of a keen sense of
dramatic timing I have no purpose but
Metro City isn't the only city right so
there are other cities to conquer and
other heroes to fight Megamind could
easily set up shop in Akron or Chicago
or even Cleveland how does Roxanne hunt
Bernards personal cell phone number but
he had taken up residence in the city's
Capitol building right so he shouldn't
be that hard to find I'll call you
tomorrow
partner even though I'm not gonna offer
you a ride home after saving me and
letting me know you walked here since we
now know we're in Michigan we also know
that the station call letters are
impossible all broadcasters east of the
Mississippi River are required to use a
W at the beginning like w m CP w jr
or w i am i still watchin this discount
despicable mean
I am your father is it a sin that Will
Ferrell is doing Brando better than
Brando and a B animated film I think it
is that's how to point Oh ships his gaze
to appear like he's looking at himself
carrying Roxanne now might be a good
time to remind the movie that this is
not how mirrors work his new line of
sight wouldn't even be anywhere near
that mirror did he grow even more on his
way down cuz if that crop top is average
width and length pal is now about 13
feet tall with a shoulder width of at
least 6 feet look I know it's a cartoon
and all but can we at least keep some
semblance of consistency why is this Jim
scoreboard on and more importantly why
is it 3 to 2 with 10 minutes and 40
seconds left after the tragic death of
metro man wouldn't continuing to use his
image on advertising be a bit tacky to
time needs to get there together okay
now you tell one how is Megan mind able
to Clark Kent Roxane like this she's
been kidnapped by Megamind many many
times and has heard him speak he has a
very distinct voice she doesn't find it
odd at all that Bernard sounds just like
him
or at the very least sounds nothing like
he did when she ran into him the first
time the back of this book is clearly
from a book called the happiest mean I
can be it doesn't show up until much
later in the movie it's almost like the
movie didn't think I'd have a pause
button on my remote I was always the
last one picked for everything hmm it's
too bad that we didn't go to the same
school yeah and then you could have made
fun of him along with everyone else
what's the T stand for Titan Titan or
Titan I know it seems like a silly
question but if you check the credits
and this joke it appears to be Titan but
this moment clearly says Titan and the
subtitle is actually switch from one to
the other about halfway through
considering Titan is just plain silly
we're gonna use Titan from here on out
and just blame the movie for its lack of
clarity either way here's an extra 5
sins movie just for making us have to
explain all that nonsense there's this
really really good-looking one I've got
my eye on currently okay fine his
superhero power has come with built-in
zoom and enhance but there is no way the
city park is in a direct line of sight
from Roxanne's apartment on the 20th
floor this high rocks on the count of
three on chief Jarrell oh it's one of
those superhero parties who you really
are not to mention you presumably
murdered two of the most important men
in their life you knew this car was
there you were just running around at
ten seconds ago does making something
invisible also
from memory like some sort of Eternal
Sunshine of the Spotless Megamind let me
make it clear
code I don't need you that movie has
time for this pointless conflict no I'm
so close I can feel it why is she
hanging all this stuff from the ceiling
at modern-day investigative reporters
traded in the evidence board for the
evidence mobile good thing Roxanne's
revelation coincided with the exact
moment all 200 pieces of paper were
facing the right direction that sure
seems convenient also what is even going
on here didn't she put these here and
they just happen to do this and why does
it even matter that she sees this but I
have powers though I'm not sure the
movie has done anything up to this point
but paint Shallow Hal is a borderline
sociopathic stalker
um how the if she's supposed to get down
from there I'm sure the movie will gloss
over any kind of explanation of how this
happens I just have her on the ground at
some point doing reporter things it's
this easy for someone to touch the watch
and ruin mega Minds disguise why
wouldn't he just put it somewhere else
on his body where it can't be as easily
reached you destroyed Metro Man you took
over the city
murdered Metro man is what he actually
did everyone seems to be tiptoeing over
that even though it's the inciting
incident do you really think that I
would ever be with you no and neither do
I which is why the end of this movie is
going to feel so false when she
eventually does ride the blue wave that
is where all this forced emotion is
going right this is a populous city and
we just saw a lot of people at the
restaurant so why are there zero people
or cars out the streets did Metro City
think there'd be a Batman vs Superman
fight downtown but other than Roxanne no
one knows who Titan is right so this was
a weird way to begin the charade the
oldest trick in the book is a guy in a
black mamba suits tearing a robot
tapping you on the shoulder that is
super specific this random billboard
seems unnecessarily Doublemint on dirt
for a kid's movie takes me back to the
good old days when animators would draw
mermaid buildings that look like dicks
[Music]
the driver of that gas truck is most
certainly dead so in Roxanne said she
might know a place she meant his pink
super layer why didn't she just lead
with that hey oh good a twist
I was hoping movie would throw another
plotline into this already tangled mess
up a story the split with minion the
romance with Roxy Titan going full
villain and now this I can't decide
which one of these boring plot lines I'm
least interested to see resolved using
my SuperSpeed I decided to go clear my
head if Metro man has this kind of
SuperSpeed doesn't that mean Titan does
as well if so why didn't he use it in
his fight with mega mind Metro man was
finally dead an music man was born oh
you've got trouble right here in Metro
City with a capital T and that rhymes
with P and that stands for put me out of
my misery already thousands have already
fled the city in a mass exodus but mega
man had taken over the city before Titan
didn't no one try to leave then oh and
just so you don't get cold feet and that
was the day that Metro City was saved by
the power of blue balls
there is no Easter Bunny there is no to
ferry spoiler alert where did all these
extra brain BOTS come from were they
hanging out with all Tony Starks extra
suits from Iron Man 3 Megaman clearly
graduated with honors from the
Prometheus school of driving away from
things know it's possible that Megamind
that turned over a new leaf for good but
why does Roxanne care he's kidnapped her
many times in the past and created a
false identity so she would fall in love
with him this is the most serious case
of Stockholm Syndrome I've ever seen
represented in an animated film so
you're the punk I've heard about even
animated superhero movies from seven
years ago just couldn't resist the sweet
sweet nectar of finishing the movie with
a super hero battling essentially a
different version of himself surprise
he's the real hero wait what
so minion has been mega mine for how
long and in the real Megaman has just
been biding his time waiting to appear
as Metro Man why is that something that
you would wait to reveal also now that I
think about it when did he even copy
Metro Man with the watch
not like he had time to do anything
between prison and trying to save
Roxanne pretty sneaky sis that one's for
all the youngsters who were just waiting
for an early 80s connect for commercial
reference your patience has been
rewarded there's only one person I know
who calls this time atrocity nice catch
Titan good thing you went ahead and flew
away scared and then waited a few
minutes to return with this knowledge
the script writers thank you
that's right the entire climax turns on
a character seeing the invisible car
from a distance no debris revealing it
or anything like that just an invisible
object that is supposedly spot able from
a hundred feet away you couldn't set
that any faster Roxanne maybe just
Megamind turn around maybe save the
sentimental crap for pillow talk later
there's a benefit to losing you get to
learn from your mistakes you can't have
it both ways movie how can both Roxie
and the blue buffoon see this car but
Titan not know what's even there so this
is how it ends
I wish Oh lo me trick but quick question
if you had the dehydration gun this
whole movie why not just dehydrate Titan
at some point think about bad guys they
always tell that to Keyser Soze the good
guys now code I guess we are cope this
running code gag should have ended 40
minutes ago except Megamind is
responsible for all of this but pain
let's just celebrate him and hope he
doesn't cup again combine those 88
consecutive life sentences short of a
memory does this city have also isn't he
still the primary suspect in the murder
of Metro Man I mean we know he's alive
and well but they don't right bad
dancing oh the worst day of my entire
life
no worries post-credits assault and
battery
Tavi Jewish God he is my day so far go
yourself San Diego maniacal laugh
maniacal laugh maybe you're just sitting
around reading Guns & Ammo masturbating
in your own feces do you just stop and
go wow it's amazing how crazy I really
am laughter Louie Armstrong when he said
he was gonna go to the moon now he's up
there laughing it down I'm afraid I just
blew myself 60% of the time it works
every time
that doesn't make sense is that hair gel